if you want to see a tragic preview
really of the voter suppression and
catastrophic disenfranchisement that
we're going to see in the November
election look no further than yesterday
in Georgia Georgia among some other
states had primary elections yesterday
and you may or may not even have heard
that elections were going on in local
elections depending on what media
sources you consume you may not even
have been aware that there were problems
or that there were even elections
yesterday but there were and this is
really it's really a crisis level
situation where the United States looks
much more like the developing countries
that are right-wing leaders often
criticize based on what our elections
looked like yesterday we had people
waiting in lines hours and hours long
outdoors in the heat often wearing masks
because we are still by the way dealing
with the corona virus pandemic of course
this was there were shortages of ballots
and this was all disproportionately in
the minority precincts parts of the
state of Georgia where the population is
majority minority places that tend on
average to vote more for Democrats than
they tend to vote for Republicans and at
some point I mean how many times are we
going to see the exact same story and
the answer is probably many sadly but
we've been watching this for election
cycle after election cycle this happened
back in Georgia back in 2018 in Georgia
that was when secretin Secretary of
State Brian Kemp a Republican was
running for governor and as Secretary of
State he oversaw his own election
against Stacey Abrams to be governor of
Georgia ultimately one big surprise and
widespread allegations of the exact same
type of voter suppression
disenfranchisement reduction of polling
places in disproportionately minority
and democratic-leaning areas it's the
same game and the reason that
Republicans are going to aggressively
push this in Georgia is that Georgia is
increasingly a contested state now I
don't want to you know pretend like it's
a battleground state in any real sense
right now
presidential e for now it's still a
state that Trump is likely going to win
modestly easily he's up in the polls
about seven points right now in Georgia
he'll almost certainly win but the point
is Georgia in local and state elections
is increasingly purple it's close enough
for Trump that he's going to have to
spend some money there which is money he
can't spend in two places he's going to
spend it there instead of somewhere else
back in 2016 Donald Trump only one
Georgia by five percentage points in the
2012 election Mitt Romney had defeated
Barack Obama by eight in Georgia and
again it's the state and local races are
maybe suggestive of what we might see in
the future in Georgia which is more of a
centrist lean than a hard right lean and
Republicans are understandably very
worried so we we saw a preview yesterday
in Georgia of what we're going to see in
a ton of places in the fall this
includes Florida Ohio Wisconsin really
it's like every contested battleground
state that was important to Trump in
2016 that he can't really afford to lose
without putting his reelection at risk
we are going to see this exact same
thing now of course lots of Georgia
voters you'll be glad to know had no
problem at all voting yesterday it's
voters who disproportionately vote in
overwhelmingly white precincts and they
were widely reporting listen I showed up
and voted in five minutes there was no
line what are people complaining about
and that's exactly the strategy make it
really easy for voters that are
statistically more likely to vote
Republican to vote make it much more
difficult for voters that at the
aggregate you know broad mathematical
level are more likely to vote for
Democrats and it's the same betrayal of
Georgia voters once again
this is election rigging we have to stop
using these softer terms like there were
reports of isolated irregularities come
on there were delays voting in some
precincts those are essentially
gaslighting terms this is rigging
because
it's intentional it's calculated it's an
effort to swing results by controlling
and manipulating and sort of molding who
gets to vote easily versus who's going
to have trouble voting so a few things
have to happen first we need as many
nonprofit groups as possible to be armed
and ready to fight every voter
suppression attempt when they try to
reduce polling places cut early voting
hours put stricter guidelines for
requesting an absentee ballot purge
voter rolls as we've seen done in a
number of different states
we need these nonprofit groups suing
every single time and gumming up any of
these attempts as much as possible
that's number one number two anybody who
can either vote early or vote absentee
should plan to vote early an or vote
absentee and should understand what the
process looks like now in some places
you will have access to both an absentee
ballot vote by mail oh and early voting
you you will have your choice of the two
in some places it's one or the other
depending on the absentee ballot rules
or the early voting rules so inform
yourself about what is going on where
you vote the absentee ballot you request
from the state ahead of time some states
are saying because of coronavirus
they'll send everybody an application
for an absentee ballot others are
looking at sending of the ballots
themselves but the point is the normal
processes you request a ballot you get
it you fill it out you mail it in that's
it you're done okay early voting is
in-person voting depending on the state
sometimes about three weeks before the
election day in this case November 3rd
early voting will start it's usually
limited locations like here in Boston if
I want to vote early I can't vote in my
neighborhood I have to go to one of I
think it's like five or six locations
including City Hall all the way downtown
find out where that is as many people as
possible should take advantage of
whichever method is available in their
state and whatever is easier for you now
one last thing the Georgia Secretary of
State says there's going to be an
investigation into what happened
yesterday now I really want you to
understand how absurd this is Brian Kemp
was Secretary of State
in November of 2018 and he ran the
election in which he was a candidate for
governor and lo and behold he won amidst
allegations of voter suppression
now another Secretary of State is going
to investigate voter suppression that he
presided over to help his own party it's
a joke we are a joke it's I got a bunch
of emails yesterday and today from
European viewers saying what's going on
in the US with your voting system like
how is this still a problem in one of
the richest countries in the world and
the answer is it's a problem by design
we could solve this but there isn't a
problem if you ask the people that
benefit from this voter suppression
there are now calls this is unbelievable
there are calls for the u.s. to bring in
United Nations elections observers in
November to try to ensure that there are
fair elections in the United States this
is how unreliable and pathetic our
election system is and we're gonna see a
lot more of it as we get closer and
closer to November if you love feeding
your intellectual curiosity but you're
always struggling to find the time check
out one of my all-time favorite apps
called blink it's linked Isleta consume
an entire book on your way home from
work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blink Asst
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
is comm slash PAC
I've put the link right underneath this
video